the division's latest update is live  well for some of you I'm Tony and this  is your testable gamespot news update  Ubisoft's public test server is  available on both steam and you play and  members can dig into the divisions  update 1.4 right now this version of the  game includes big changes like new gear  stats weapon damage and balancing to get  in you just need to own a copy of the  game and have the public test server  downloaded note that it's a full client  with a hefty 45 gigabyte file size  participating players can send feedback  to Ubisoft via forums on the official  site update 1.4 is still being developed  for a full release with the division  survival DLC planned for later this year  the third expansion last stand is slated  for early 2017 if that schedule changes  again you'll hear about it from GameSpot  and for all the latest on the division  you're already in the right place